this is where we came up with the
cerebral inhibitor to use against a bow
oh you have a gun there yet clash
pegging see here it is in the future you
and I have been enemies for years there
have been others of course it's gone
zoun DeVoe none of them hurt you
likes avatar truly broke you to be
honest so I don't look at jealous but
now it's like I get to kill them too
from the mouth of the writers DeVoe is
going to be the villain so everybody's
asking about season four you guys want
to know what's going on we're actually
going to get a lot more information in
the next couple months especially before
we get to comic-con when they drop the
first real trailer so there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video we're
going to be doing this all summer so
these are going to be my top 10
predictions for season 4 some of these
or slam dunks they're super easy they
set them up correctly either in the
final episode or the previous episodes
before that in some of these are just
based on the direction that the riders
are going and what they've said about
how they're going to be different in
season 4 from previous seasons so number
10 this is the easy one fairy will be
back in the first episode remember what
happened with flashpoint we hear
flashpoint we're like oh my god is it
going to be like this dystopian comic
book thing all season long nope that
lasted for one episode berry went back
changed things again and sort of reset
to base with the exception of sabotage
Julian and all the big character shifts
that they wanted to introduce like
Caitlyn becoming killer frost so number
9 the important stuff the reason that
he's back in the mechanism that brings
him back will be a combination of Tracy
brand working in the Speed Force trying
to learn more about it in iris acting as
his lightning rod so if you haven't been
reading flash rebirth they just
reintroduced this idea in a really big
way they brought back the
gerrae character they brought back the
ginger Wally West character this way too
so when speedsters die they go to the
Speed Force but one of the fun things
about the flash is that a lot of its
story beads and logic draw from the
science of electricity so you have
lightning rods that sort of act as
attractors for this discharge of
electricity so even though the Speed
Force is like dark matter energy Barry
is pure energy right now while he's in
the Speed Force that's why they couldn't
see savat are only speedsters could see
him because they were attuned to the
Speed Force
so flash rebirth style Wally will
probably get a vision of Barry but his
team flash finds a way to bring him back
it'll take iris in order to get him to
stick so if the proposal in episode 17
wasn't clear enough
they're obviously pushing into the very
iris relationship so she's always going
to be the most important character for
his character so she'll probably be one
of the most important pieces of bringing
him back permanently but number eight
they will use the flash rebirth twist
with the Speed Force storm to surface
new metas not new speedsters but new
metas so that's a little bit of a change
from the comics but every year the
disaster of the finale is the engine
that creates all the new metas and
villains for the next season that are
always very clear about that so pre
season one you have the particle
accelerator explosion that creates all
the normal metas then at the end of
season one you have the giant wormhole
in the sky that opens up the breaches to
earth - so we get all the earth -
villains then at the end of season three
you have flash points so you get all the
flash point husks that become villains
like the rival at the beginning of the
season most of these metas will just be
regular metas from the comics now they
always bring back fan favorites so all
the villains of season four will be a
combination of old favorites twist on
old favorites like we see alternate
versions of enemies that we've seen
before sometimes like different versions
of killer frost and then whatever new
ones they want to use this speed for
storm to surface like oh you know this
dark matter energy just activated a
whole bunch of new characters so number
seven everybody wants to know what about
speedsters though we introduced so many
new speedsters during season 3 there
will continue to be
speedster villains but the main villain
will not be a speedster like
reverse-flash Zhu Morse avatar now if
you haven't read the comics the
reverse-flash is sort of like Barry's
ultimate villain he'll always be his
ultimate nemesis but like you've seen
season 1 he was the main villain season
2 he continued to be a villain but not
in the same way season 3 same thing so
the relationship between Barry and
eobard thawne will continue to deepen in
really interesting ways but number 6
because they killed the black flash
there will be a new black flash
eventually maybe not right away but they
might choose to go with the flash
rebirth twist from Geoff Johns rebirths
not the one from last year there's two
different versions of flash rebirth the
first one was when Geoff Johns formally
brought Barry Allen back eel Bart Don
poisoned him with the negative Speed
Force he temporarily became the black
flash so anytime he would touch a
speedster his negative charge would sort
of cancel out their Speed Force energy
and they would have vaporized into
nothingness so I'm not expecting them to
do that but there will be a version of
the black flash back eventually and
it'll be another speedster character
there's always some fun twist on that
number 5 they spent a whole bunch of
episode 21 teasing bart allen who is the
grandson of Barry and iris they'll
continue to tease him but I don't think
that we're going to see Bart Allen
full-on till much much further in the
future they haven't teased Barry and
iris children yet so they'll continue to
tease that as well but they will do the
Barry iris wedding at some point so you
see the wedding once they do that then
you'll start seeing jokes about them
having kids they'll start teasing the
tornado twins but it's not like iris is
going to have a baby if we see their
children it'll be a flash forward we're
not going to see her actually give birth
on the TV show number 4 the roster of
team flash will get cycled so Caitlin
will continue to help the team out she's
going to be a series regular but when
she says she needs to figure things out
that's mostly for the break she'll be
back in the first episode but it's not
going to be like it was before
killer frost in the comics right now is
a member of the Justice League they
changed her character a little bit she
used to be more of a straight-up villain
so they try to make her a little more
sympathetic she doesn't want to use her
powers to leech the heat for mother
people that will be the version of
Caitlyn that you see in season 4 the
more complicated version more
interesting I should say they'll
probably play with the makeup just a
little bit too because you look at it
here and you actually can't tell that
she's killer frost she actually looks
like the girl from iZombie so I think
that they'll tweak that just a little
bit they'll add a little bit more blue
to her but Tracy brand will probably
become a series regular and fill her
spot so she'll be like the scientist
that we used to have in Harrison wells
and sort of lighten the tone because now
Caitlyn has the edge back she's not
going to be the perky happy person that
she was in previous seasons in Harrison
wells from earth-2 will come back for
the first couple of episodes and balance
that tone out so everybody that they
have on team flash just sort of balances
the tone out and Julian will come back
to for Caitlyn but we don't know if he's
going to be a series regular so they'll
confirm all those things really soon
like they'll say so and so up to series
regular so-and-so coming back for
partial season so they might cycle the
roster again halfway through the year
Jessie quick is going to come back of
course the reverse slash is going to
come back Jessica Camacho is going to
come back as gypsy but I don't expect
her to be a serious regular in number
three though Suicide Squad characters
that they teeth will also come back and
get a big episode
gorilla grodd king shark cheetah it's
going to be really expensive to do them
so they might amortize that over two
episodes so I think I said that during
their episode when they popped up
they'll probably do like a big two-part
episode where they get to do something
really cool so number two speaking of
big crossover episodes the four-way
crossover will be a true four-way
crossover meaning like that episode of
Supergirl will actually genuinely
contribute to the plot of the crossover
and they'll continue to tease TV Justice
League Superfriends so like they have
that warehouse that they turned into the
Hall of the Justice on the flash they'll
continue to do things like that I don't
think that they're contractually allowed
to use the term Justice League on the TV
show they said they have not written the
story for what that big crossover is
going to be but they have some ideas in
because they had so much success with
the dominators because the ratings for
that were so high just expected to be
some big huge CG action set piece so
number one this is probably the easiest
/
nation to make devote in the rogue's are
going to be the main villains of season
now which rogues are up for grabs like
Captain cold always comes back
but unless Wentworth Miller wants to be
a series regular on the flash it's a
little bit harder to use him but you'll
get like a tease for them in the first
couple of episodes then towards the
middle of the season they'll do the big
reveal there is a schedule that they
keep - when it comes to revealing who
the villain is them appearing on screen
doing the big evil villain monologue we
didn't really see Savitt are full on -
like episode 6 episode 7 I would expect
a similar timetable for DeVoe and
whichever rogue that show up but I'll do
some more videos about who DeVoe is and
how he works with the Rogues because the
Rogues precede him he's just a normal
person who comes up with the idea to use
them together and form this big team use
them like a puppet master would so
expect a lot of really classic rogue
action the first couple of episodes then
you'll probably see DeVoe get the idea
to start using them in an organized way
in whatever his plan is we'll start to
surface but like they said neural
inhibitor DuBose powers involve mind
control so they will be using some of
team flash against each other until they
figure out how to fight his powers so
let me know in the comments what are all
your predictions for season 4 what do
you want to see them do and leave all
your requests for flash bonus videos in
the comments below I know some of you
have requested videos for the flash
Batman Button storyline The Watchmen
stuff the Doomsday Clock the Jeff John's
tease there will be comic book bonus
videos too so it'll be a combination of
TV show stuff as well as comics this
summer congratulations to Angelico m
you're the latest giveaway winner it was
a new round in this video I'll announce
the winner the next time I post a DC
video while you wait for everything you
can click here to rewatch that Game of
Thrones season 7 trailer and you can
click here for my arrow and flash finale
videos thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you